hi I'm BL Garrett I'm a documentary
filmmaker I make films on ordinary
average everyday people everybody's got
a story I got into filmmaking about
three and a half years ago I wanted to
make a film on my 88 year old
grandfather he grew up poor on a farm in
Oklahoma his father was a sharecropper
he served in World War two in the South
Pacific and later went on to start his
own business and have a successful
career he's really a modern-day John
Wayne I knew nothing about filmmaking
and really all my resources came from
YouTube which is kind of a scary thought
there's so much information out there
and I spent hundreds and hundreds of
hours researching cameras lighting audio
tripods mono pods shotgun mics lavalier
mics recorders I mean you name it so
today I'm going to talk about the
equipment that I did I landed on and how
it's worked for me and the strengths and
some of the weaknesses of my equipment
the first thing I'll talk about is my
camera I landed on a Panasonic gh3 at
the time the gh2 was still out and kind
of all the rage you could on Vimeo
YouTube I mean I was seeing this
beautiful footage of hacked gh twos and
I was amazed by you know really how
small the camera was and that intrigued
me you know I I thought to get footage
like that it had to be this big bulky
camera that you know sat on your
shoulder and and I was just unaware that
you know a DSLR type camera could do
something like that I ended up going
with the gh3 for a couple of reasons the
main reason was battery life I can
literally I can literally on one battery
use my gh3 for almost five hours and
another thing that I like about my gh3
is that I can put a hundred and twenty
eight gig SD card in and film at 50
megabits per second for five and a half
hours which is remarkable so I always
have 228 gig cards on me I have two
batteries on me so if I ever go out to a
shoot say I have a subject I'm making a
film and I go out and I have an
eight-hour day I can film all day with
those two batteries and really one SD
card tell you the truth I sometimes use
another go to the other SD card but you
know usually the the one SD card gets me
through the day some of the things I
really like about the gh3 is that it
will film in 60 frames per second 30
frames per second 24 frames per second I
usually use it 24 frames per second it
films up to 72 megabits per second but I
usually use the 50 megabits per second
and 24 frames per second and it really
it really gives me the HD the 1080p HD
quality that I'm looking for I also love
the LCD screen in the back it flips out
it swivels so whenever I'm interviewing
somebody and I'm sitting I'm sitting
next to the camera I can I can pull the
LCD screen out sideways and I can
monitor you know the footage to make
sure that we're still recording to make
sure that we're in focus that that's a
huge thing it's got an HDMI output that
I love and it's also got real-time audio
jack where I can plug headphones in and
listen to to the in-camera Audio audio
wise I use to zoom h1 recorders and I
use two I have two lavalier mics that
are made by giant squid this is really a
great bargain you know if you're just
getting into filmmaking there's a lot of
recorders out there that I'm sure are
much better quality but if you're kind
of just getting into filmmaking and you
want to step up your game to have
something better than your
in camera audio I highly recommend the
zoom h1 they cost $99 a piece and the
giant squid lavalier mic cost $50 so
basically two audio recorders and two
lavalier mics for $300 is a great
bargain I also have a rode videomic pro
shotgun mic that I mount on the hot shoe
on top of the gh3 camera I use that
really to sync the audio with the with
the recorded sound that I get from their
recorders and lavalier mic I also use it
for b-roll footage you know just kind of
the background noise and kind of chatter
it works out great the gh3 is great
because you know the Micro Four Thirds
camera it looks like a stills camera
like just a regular picture camera and
it's really great when I'm out in public
I'm getting b-roll footage people think
that I'm taking pictures they don't know
that I'm getting the footage from this
little this little powerhouse a lot of
times friends and family you know that
I've seen a lot of my stuff I'll be out
and I'll have my camera and they'll be
like hey well what camera do you use
when you when you make your when you
make your films and I'm like this camera
right here and it's it's really it's
really amazing the footage I get from it
it doesn't shoot 4k but I don't really
need 4k yet you know I am looking to
upgrade in the next six months or so I
might go to the Panasonic gh4 but I can
tell you right now I looked on B&H photo
and you can buy a brand new gh3 for five
hundred and forty-nine dollars and I'm
seriously considering going that way I
always always always when I have a job I
always rent an additional camera usually
the Panasonic gh3 I use Lin Lin's rental
comm they've done me right I've used
them probably two dozen times they they
always ship it on time it's you know
it's my kick my same camera of course
have the lenses for it so I always have
that for a backup and I use one for a
wide-angle shot and a close-up shot for
my films so if one fails me I've got the
backup let's talk about lenses when I
first got the camera something that I
had learned from the dru Network he
talked about these iconic lenses that
were made in the 80s by nikkor so I
bought a 28 millimeter F 2.8 AIS and I
bought a nikkor 50 millimeter 1.8 ai
these lenses were made in the early 80s
and it's some of the it's some of the
greatest glass I've ever seen the cool
thing about it is I buy all my lenses
used at KEH comm and these lenses were
were not that expensive I mean I
literally I think for the two lenses I
spent like almost $300 so those were
really my first two lenses I also
purchased a 14 millimeter Panasonic
pancake lens I believe it's a f/2 and a
half so that was kind of my wide angle
and it had autofocus which is nice when
you're shooting b-roll you're kind of
following somebody trying to do some
some Steadicam work with your wide-angle
it really it was really a nice piece to
my to my collection but all my early
films I used the 50 millimeter and the
28 millimeter to interview my subjects
and all my all my filming was pretty
much done with that I've added two more
lenses to my collection since then last
year I purchased a Olympus 45 millimeter
and it's an F 1.8 and it is a beautiful
portrait lens I mean for taking pictures
and filming I mean this is like one of
my favorite lenses and I bought it I
think for $250 brand-new on Amazon and I
think it was an international version
you even get up warranty with it but you
know I'll roll the dice on that to save
100 bucks
secondly my last lens and
most favorite lens is the panasonic 12
to 35 millimeter that's what I'm filming
myself on right now with my Panasonic
gh3 it's got autofocus and it's got
onboard stabilization this this this
lens I think I fell in love with that
Griffin Hammond made a documentary
called sriracha and he made the whole
documentary with my Panasonic gh3 and a
Panasonic 12 to 35 millimeter and I was
like blown away with clarity how it
looked and I I wanted to have one at the
time it was like $1,200 I couldn't
afford that so you know I waited a year
and a half and I just bought one without
the warranty on Amazon for seven hundred
and sixty-five dollars so it's been a
great addition
it's nice when I interview somebody I
mean the the the worst thing ever is is
interviewing somebody for for an hour
and a half and then going home to edit
and you pull up the footage and it's
soft I mean just soft enough where
you're like I can't use this footage and
you know it looked great when I when I
focused in on them but it was soft so
with the with the new lens I don't have
to worry about that with a 45 millimeter
or the twelve to thirty five millimeter
the Panasonic gh3 has a two times crop
factor so my 45 millimeter really is a
90 millimeter and the 12 to 35 comes out
to 24 to 70 millimeter focal length
price was price was really a major
factor in purchasing the used Panasonic
gh3 from keh calm
I believe I bought it for for $800 used
one thing about keh comm is that how
they how they market the condition of
the equipment is it's like no other I
mean if it says like new I mean it is
it's brand new I mean they have
excellent and then you know it goes all
the way down to bargain
and I've had friends that have bought in
bargain lenses and there was nothing
wrong with them they were great one
thing I want to mention today about the
companies I'm talking about that I've
done business with in no way am I paid
by these companies I'm just a satisfied
customer and believe me you can check my
bank account it's not that big thank you
guys so much for watching if you ever
have any questions you can contact me
directly at BL at BL Garrett films.com
have a great day